hallo everybody and welcome to a brand
new episode of my one-hour flipping
challenge today we're gonna be flipping
barrows items only for one hour now
we're gonna start with 30 Milligan
because you guys suggested it and yeah
so beyond the actual barrows items there
will be a couple other ones that come
from the chests like death runes chaos
runes and blood rooms along with the
dragon med helm and the Lupin toothed
half of the key began mainly the Bears
Eames will be the focus for today and
yeah let's see how it goes let's get
started okay we are ready to go we have
30 mil in the inventory one hour on the
clock and we're gonna flippin Drock
rewards which will mainly be the the
armor pieces but of course other things
cam as well so let's go one hour on the
clock we are going to start with D to
rock set for sure it's definitely most
traded up armor sets and we are pretty
much just guessing on this here now or
start low and we'll work our way up from
there start with four new form to begin
with these do have about over a thousand
traded every day so we should be able to
get them assuming we have the right
price next I'm just kind of guessing
here with you Agustin's armor set off to
change price ranks I really have no idea
5k do one of those
and so we got those in Early's we'll
build a tree just a price if we don't on
the right have time for that next we
might do some quicker items that we have
available not that many the chaos rune
and the death ruin any blood rune as
well as the full track loop half in 2000
Matt Helm that's it pretty well one over
nine and you're selling for one hundred
that's pretty good actually and do
11,000 now we haven't bought eat your ox
armor set yet not really sure it's been
about five minutes these should be
coming quicker than that I believe so I
think we're gonna raise up the price a
bit okay we have a first two rocks armor
set piece actually so we've got them for
2010 and I will try sell them for 2017
that's right 2100 to start with okay so
we're just checking the margin on what
we get for combining crystal keys and
we're gonna get let's see so 33 8 for 8
-
six nine eight two minus two four four
eight five 2340 that's quite nice as
well go ahead and start buying some of
these and maybe 200 that might be a
little I don't know about that
we'll see ya and the two halves were
buying for 24 or 95 that's right
actually and there we go we just
actually sold the Drakh set this week
got a 65 k profit there actually so
that's pretty nice
okay we bought 80 rocks timer said
actually we need to buy more though we
only put in one Maxim and 2015 seems to
be good so we'll go ahead and buy maybe
another for those claisen you'd be
buying pretty quickly like I thought
okay we stole off our than when we
bought another one actually that's going
quite nice so that's another 60 K right
there and we have another drawing piece
in we'll put in for another 60 K profit
what
that was buggy but uh hey put that in
there okay we buy the guns or armor set
so this can be interesting with can
actually sell it for so we offer 61 90k
we're gonna wait until we sell this
before it buy another one named deferens
we will put in for 2055 and the limits
10,000 on these things we got a bunch of
bull racks but we also sold leader ox
armor set which is sweet as another 60k
perfect rock armor set try buying them
for 1600 we'll start to I think well the
weight we might as well just combine
these keys and you can start selling
them might as well expiry happen I
didn't know he just basically hit pop
them in your bank withdraw well I can
execute 14 this time fortunately I would
cash stack and I don't want to posit
that just toss them both the keys down
here there's something like that and you
just BAM click them together and
actually gonna do Rockstar Merced that's
nice
fortunately you don't have much room
left anymore for these keys go in
Wow it sold very quickly 260 to 270 so
let's put in for that because we want to
flip more in one of these okay we sold
it already okay so we have a weird
margin here but we shall do it
guns armor set bought it for
let's get paper up in here bought for 60
190 be sold for 62 to 7 I'm a massive
margin but we will put an offer in for a
bit less to see 61 maybe K about and and
we'll do two and we bought the guns
armor set forth sleeve don't have
anywhere to sell it in okay we sold
another gustin's armor set that really
do not take very long okay back spot
another defens armor set sweet in 10,000
limit on the blood room leaving us with
almost no money
both the death runes and the guns armor
pieces have sold our armor set sorry
that's tonight's we're gonna there's 37k
on that and the death runes we got
oh who knows
I think five GP on each is probably for
you to care so and we've got back to
waiting that the only other item that we
can realistically do is the dragon mid
helm but not touching that thing again
the blood runes have totally sold
actually that's actually quite nice we
had a six GP margin on those that's good
we got another armor set actually sweet
we still just sell this one though so we
have to to sell now so he pretty much
stuck until they've sold Oh bull racks
tanked it oh my god spent so much time
buying those well we might as well sell
them back I guess for not losing very
much but didn't gain anything out that
unfortunately okay chaos Rudin right now
the two GP margin let's go for it
chaos rune 101 10000
we here seriously raising at this
drock's armor set we want to buy a
couple more it's up to 21 20 K this is
just a total guess to be honest we
readjusted the chaos rooms as well for
ox Armour said no luck there oh my god
we instantly bought tutor ox armor sets
oh boy
oh we stole the guns armor set finally
oh they're both sold what that I'm so
confused man oh we sold into rocks armor
sets that is actually insane that's a
solid drop on that actually nice oh and
there goes the other one sweet okay we
should try to buy more of these will he
buy them for him
29 3 J and he's so little time left
man that sucks that was a huge flip just
in there we got on each one 20 to 90 -
1:22 19-21 3160 aah that's insane
Oh about two more oh my god okay we
actually sold one more drock's armor set
that is insane
that's another 135k profit or something
sweet we have seven minutes left so
we're gonna try to sell the last one the
bolt racks sold a good amount of those
not quite all of them unfortunately okay
sorry I'm dare it is the final Roxette
is sold as insane we made complete Bank
on these sets just how I imagined it's
perfect we cut five minutes left so we
realistic have enough time to do much
sell the chaos room maybe back for we
bottom floor okay we totally sold the
chaos turns off as we I don't know we
broke even I'm pretty sure yeah but look
at these flips look at that right there
that is insane two flips of almost 300 K
few more that was 400 what
that's insane we're actually have a
pretty decent profit from this one the
Roxette is the only thing I made money
I'm pretty well the captain said mind
you it to make probably a hundred can
that the Drock stylin we meet probably
close to the mill okay guys we are down
to 30 seconds remaining I am pretty sure
these aren't selling unfortunately the
good thing is again like I said the keys
will still prophetís I think one 1000
each with roughly
not entirely sure about that but I think
pretty pretty close to that Bowl tracks
we were losing to GP on so probably is
about 15k or something
mind you we have to dump them I think
for 95 coins was a low price alright 7
seconds left 5 4 3 2 oh wow I just hold
something more this zero seconds left
timers up so let's pull everything out
before we sell anymore and crystals out
out
okay so we shall sell all these out off
see if we sell them all for that price
there we go all sold now the bolt racks
gonna have to lower down a bit probably
95 name we'll be losing
it and bolt racks but whatever whoo whoo
look at that boys we got at least one
mil this episode that is insane it's not
as much of a suspenseful not as much
suspense sorry by that weather so let's
see how much we made from one-hour
flippin barrows items we have made 30
1.2 mil is what we have now giving this
a 1.2 mil profit that is awesome not
even close to anything else at me before
1.2 mil an hour is pretty sweet drock's
carried that for sure I'm I'm almost
positive 1 1 mil of that profit was
pretty much drock's maybe a bit less
maybe like Eeyore 900k but still I would
got very lucky theme at the margin if
you're wondering I was legitimately just
guessing I think leaned that the set may
have gone up a bit because I've been
this is a thousand tree of the day and I
should be buying one every couple
minutes realistically and ahead and
bought one for almost 20 minutes half an
hour most so we decided jacket up but we
bought at an extremely high price so I'm
just guessing that the price would be
much higher so we just finally put it in
managed to sell one and then we just
reassessed the margin from there happy
yeah I hope you guys enjoyed and I will
see you guys in the next episode